[Música]
economía en directo América de France 24
nos acompaña en el estudio nuevamente
volvió a casa Daniela Blandón Daniela
buena mañana de jueves estaba por allá
en el cubrimiento de la frontera en
Venezuela Pues bueno
Claro que sí Bueno aquí ya estás en la
nevera de Bogotá como le dicen vamos a
Reino Unido que también es frío para
tratar que trata digamos de defender su
política económica Dani si Raúl Pues es
que como hemos venido también informando
a todos estos días acá en economía la
libra esterlina ha estado en caída libre
después de que el gobierno anunciara el
pasado viernes un plan de agresivos
recortes Fiscales que el fondo monetario
internacional salió a criticar porque
entre otros este proyecto lo que hace es
disparar la deuda pública que ya de por
sí está bastante alta el banco de
Inglaterra también tuvo que intervenir
el mercado citando un riesgo material
para la estabilidad financiera en el
Reino Unido hoy la primera ministra
listros salió a defender este plan por
eso estamos con Luisa Pulido quien es
nuestra corresponsal en Londres y Luisa
con los buenos días y las buenas tardes
allá le pregunto cuál fue esta respuesta
del destroza y Qué tan grave es esta
situación para los mercados y para los
británicos en general
Buenas tardes después de casi una semana
de silencio la primera ministra como lo
mencionas defendió este paquete
financiero que ha generado una crisis
estrepitosa en la caída de la libra
esterlina que ha llegado a niveles
históricos listas dijo que esta paquete
es absolutamente necesario para impulsar
el crecimiento económico del país y que
está preparada para tomar decisiones
impopulares por supuesto el precio de la
libra esterlina sigue cayendo porque los
mercados y los inversionistas están
nerviosos algunos de estos ya están
sacando de hecho sus recursos de este
país y llevándolos a otros territorios
como lo mencionaba hace el nerviosismo
se da porque este paquete financiero que
incluye el mayor recorte de impuestos en
los últimos 50 años también aumenta el
endeudamiento público que ya también es
altísimo Así que el impacto en la
población ya se da en el aumento en los
precios de los alimentos importados
también en los también es importados
como la gasolina y gas Porque estos
están tasados en dólares también se
prevé que aumentarán los precios de las
hipotecas que se pagan por las casas y
tomar vacaciones en el exterior con el
dólar tan alto será ahora muchísimo más
caro y especialmente ahora que viene
Raúl la temporada más fría del año la
temporada más fría del año vamos a ver
cómo pega el invierno en Reino Unido en
Europa y pues bueno en Bogotá que casi
que vivimos en invierno prácticamente
como siempre por la información un gran
abrazo nosotros Dani continuamos con más
información económica porque hay una
nueva fuga en el gasoducto northream la
estamos reportando también esta mañana
en nuestro programa que conecta este
caso doctor recordemos a Rusia con
Europa
la guardia costera sueca informó sobre
una cuarta fuga en este tubo que lleva
gas ruso a Alemania específicamente dos
de las fugas están en la tubería
northrimundo que recientemente dejó de
suministrar ga mientras que las otras
dos están en North Stream 2 que nunca
comenzó a operar aunque no estaban
funcionando ambas tuberías estaban
llenas de gas que se escapó y burbujeo
hacia la superficie y ya hay por
supuesto van a reacciones en todos los
frentes Claro que si el kremlin a través
de su portavoz dimitrip Scott asegura
que esto parece ser un producto de un
acto terrorista seguramente patrocinado
por algún estado occidental la otana lo
califica de Sabotaje deliberado e
irresponsable la Unión Europea por su
parte que también sospecha de un
Sabotaje dijo estar investigando y de
hecho sus líderes planean reunirse la
próxima semana para analizar algo que
consideran ha cambiado fundamentalmente
la naturaleza del conflicto con Ucrania
también para diseñar un octavo paquete
de sanciones contra Rusia por todos
estos hechos y hoy Hay huelga nacional
en Francia Dani Por qué Raúl esta huelga
fue convocada por varios sindicatos de
extrema izquierda que exigen los
comentarios más altos y también que se
oponen a la reforma pensional propuesta
por Emmanuel macron el movimiento
provocó una interrupción en el sector
energético Porque muchos trabajadores de
la industria de la energía nuclear
también se unieron a la huelga en
Francia está encendido el debate porque
el gobierno quiere presentar antes de
Navidad una reforma pensional que
incluya Un aumento progresivo en la edad
de jubilación que hoy es de 62 años
planea llevarla a 65 años en los
próximos años la intención de este
proyecto es que sea votado a principios
de 2023 y que entre en vigencia en algún
momento del próximo año Según dijo hoy
el ministro de trabajo y venimos a
nuestra región porque en Argentina hay
menos pobreza pero más personas en la
calle tenemos datos frescos más Raúl del
Instituto Nacional de estadística y
censos que reveló el miércoles que la
tasa de pobreza bajó en el primer
semestre del año al
36,5%, esto desde un 37,3% en la segunda
mitad de 2021 sin embargo la tasa de
indigencia si subió lo hizo en 0,6
puntos porcentuales pasó del 8,2% el año
pasado al 8,8% en el primer semestre de
este año un dato sobre el cual ha
llamado la atención la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández en su cuenta de
Twitter La funcionaria aseguró que las
empresas alimentarias han aumentado
significativamente sus márgenes de
rentabilidad de paso reconoció que
aunque el Ministerio de economía ha
hecho un buen trabajo también se
necesita una política de intervención
más precisa y más efectiva en el sector
y al mismo tiempo diseñar un instrumento
que refuerce esa seguridad alimentaria Y
es que Raúl el objetivo de reducir la
pobreza en Argentina se está enfrentando
como lo sabemos al escollo de la
persistente inflación en el primer
semestre del año los precios han subido
esos 36,2% junio enero a junio pero si
los precios de hoy los comparamos con
los de hace un año suben un 70% Raúl
cifra del día bueno primero lo invito a
que veamos las siguientes imágenes y ya
le doy la cifra del día
[Aplausos]
Raúl 75.000 millones de euros ya lo veía
usted del campanazo en la bolsa de
Frankfurt en la apertura de este jueves
Este es el valor de Mercado con el que
hizo su Debut la firma de autos de lujo
Porsche Ya lo hemos hablado del grupo
Volkswagen se convierte entonces en la
segunda salida bolsa más grande de
Alemania desde que Dodge Telecom lo hizo
en 1996 y supera Inclusive la
capitalización bursátil de su competidor
Ferrari capitalización bursátil es el
valor en bolsa el número de acciones por
el valor las acciones en bolsa se
cotizaban entonces sobre los 85 euros a
punto del cierre de mercado por encima
del precio que fueron emitidas de 82,5
euros cada una Volkswagen entonces
recaudó unos 19.400 millones de euros en
un movimiento
en un momento que hay turbulencia en el
mercado Raúl las acciones europeas están
en su peor año desde 2009 hay guerra en
Ucrania alta inflación aumento de tasas
de interés crisis energética mundial de
todo pero bueno estamos en nuestro mundo
es así ya acostumbrados a todo esto yo
me imaginé que llegamos a tanto Dani
como siempre Gracias más adelante más
economía pasamos a saludar a Luis Méndez
Zurich con todos los